[Music]
it is my third night here in chicago
ladies and gentlemen yeah
third night third night in chicago
and it's already come to this hi my name
is conan and i'm an alcoholic
there's something about this town
i don't know what it is it's not just me
it's the entire state i know
after every show we gotta go
and it's it's a happy kind of drink it
is a happy drink it's not a stressful
kind no it's the part later that's sad
uh
we're at a very nice hotel here in
chicago i went to turn in last night and
the maid left a rack of ribs on my
pillow
[Laughter]
this is exciting news president obama is
coming to chicago this weekend did you
know that yeah
true
yeah uh obama is introducing his new
economic plan as part of the just for
laughs festival uh
somehow
yes
this is a fun fact fun fact on their
first date president obama reportedly
took his wife michelle to the art
institute of chicago yeah
yeah meanwhile on their first date mitt
romney bought his wife the art institute
of chicago
[Applause]
it's hard to find shoes to go with that
no it's very hard yeah
you guys fall in sports yesterday the
chicago cubs fired their hitting coach
isn't that
isn't that incredible the cubs had a
hitting coach
[Applause]
who holds a bat like that
i read this today the chicago transit
authority has announced it's going to
sell tickets for the l over groupon
nice it's good
in a related story the guy on the l
offering to show you his penis for a
dollar is now accepting paypal
[Applause]
i i still don't understand why i have to
pay him
[Laughter]
it's very impressive uh
what's up so we were here here just a
couple years ago things have changed a
lot since the last time i was in this
town today oprah asked me if i could
spot her 20 bucks until the weekend
a little bit of difficulty
[Laughter]
she's walking right now
you still don't want to piss that woman
off yeah i know he said what
destroy him
gold robots come after me
they're not very effective they just
send in the ineffective gold robots
that just do this
speaking of oprah this week oprah
winfrey will interview eight members of
the kardashian family
yeah
it's in an episode of oprah's show
entitled i can't believe it's come to
this
[Applause]
speaking of reality stars nude photos of
snooki have surfaced online
[Applause]
yeah it's either that or pictures of a
bright orange basketball being inflated
you